the women in our parents generation
they were more into femininity you know
what i mean
because i think you would just look
great in a dress
but i mean if you were pretty much done
actually thank you if it's cool i'm just
going to snag these leftovers
i don't know how you do it molly
do it dating people
no no
you do not need a man okay
so don't play the games just be you
straight out the gate
do you live around here
because i live on aisle six
that was terrible
it was kind of terrible
what's his instagram i want to stalk a
little bit he doesn't have one say what
yeah oh no see that's that's shady let's
play a game tell me something you don't
want me to know i
hate this okay i feel all our hopes of
finding happiness through someone else
yeah
girl you're all dygmatized and i haven't
even seen this dude
what's going on i'm going to tell you
but you're going to freak out
no this isn't happening
yeah it's happening
no games not what you wanted
it's about giving
giving yourself over to somebody
[Music]
becoming one forever
that's love
[Music]
it's a straight girl's fantasy come true
right
[Music]
you